What I do requires a certain mindset.
I do assignments.
Some jobs need to look like accidents.
The best jobs are the ones nobody even knows you're there.
There's no one better than you, you know.
You need someone to watch your back.
I have you, Harry.
Harry McKenna sold this company out.
He had to be removed.
Sorry about your father.
I wanna know what you know.
Follow me.
Know what a mechanic is?
A hitman.
Now, to take your training to the next level.
So what's the plan now?
Time to finish the job.
Those were my best teams.
Guess I'll have to send more.
Save the fuel.
We're coming for you.
You think you can get to me before I get to you?
I already have.
Do it.